well let's just uh jump into this first
story check it out from Yahoo George
Floyd's daughter announces 250 million
dollar lawsuit against Kanye West and
then it says the mother of George
Floyd's daughter announced they are
filing a 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Kanye West over his recent
statements about Floyd's death the
rapper who goes by yay erroneously
declared that a podcast that Floyd died
from fentanyl not as the result of
police brutality now you see I love how
they say he erroneously declared uh no
Kanye defiantly declared he was
basically saying I don't agree with your
assessment that it was police brutality
now the official coroners report says I
think it was the police action and there
were contributing factors which included
heart disease and uh drug use the report
actually showed I believe
that he had fentanyl norefentanyl THC
methamphetamine in a system and and uh
nicotine as well yeah nicotine so he's
smoking cigarettes there's five drugs
yeah wow and I guess the report was that
he was chewing on a speed ball which is
like meth and Fentanyl combined or
something is that what it is I suppose
cocaine and heroin I think combined but
in this case we fentanyl oh okay so
apparently he was like chewing on it and
then he spit it out or whatever I don't
know so look this is Kanye West's
opinion he's allowed to have one he
watched a documentary it's ridiculous
that you can sue for that I mean you can
sue a ham sandwich doesn't mean you're
gonna win Kanye's comments are repugnant
attempt to Discount George Floyd's life
and to profit from his inhumane death
attorney Pat D Dixon the third sent a
statement on Tuesday adding that the
goal with the lawsuit is to hold Mr West
accountable for his flagrant remarks
yeah he also had covid and a lot of
people were pointing out uh particularly
Jack was hoping that he was also
unvaccinated so he was like take that
leftist oh yeah but but again this is
just an opinion and I think you know we
I was kind of talking about the story on
my program yesterday and I'm like this
could be the The Alex Jones precedent
that has been set here as we've seen
Alex Jones has now been sued by the
family members that that he uh
criticized to the tune of one billion
dollars and uh I I think this is going
to be an important verdict that I think
they're going to be playing off in this
particular court case to try to stifle
people from expressing opinions that
they don't like and it's just crazy you
know where's Free Speech where's the
First Amendment we should be able to
exercise our ability to say whatever we
want
so Tim is it all right if I just set
this one out I don't really want to be
sued here okay is that okay all right
I'm totally joking now I mean look the
mother of George Floyd's daughter I
don't what what's that
well I guess confused here there's no
baby mama yeah that's what I'm thinking
yeah something like that'll be George
Floyd's baby mama is that is that I'm
trying to make sure I got his girlfriend
though they weren't official no like
baby mama meaning like someone you had a
kid with yeah right so so the
appropriate term would be baby mama yeah
I think that's that I think you're right
anyway I was just kidding about setting
this one out but well you don't want to
get sued we could get August sued by you
know what we say here today because if
this is I'm not I I don't care I'm
actually being sued right now by uh St
Luke's for defamation Hospital yes oh no
way oh because I stood for uh family
where they were involved in taking their
child through a CPS case and I I rallied
a bunch of people and and we got the we
got the child back to his parents
and then later St Luke sued me oh wow
for defamation so look I mean it was not
it's not it's not quarter million or a
quarter billion dollars but hey quarter
million yeah
250 million oh yeah Alex Jones they you
saw that story right 965 million dollars
that's the meme now like whenever
someone's caught lying you just say like
I demand 965 million dollars no a lot of
people need to understand like he wasn't
just ordered by the judge to pay 965
million it was like 50 million for this
family 60 million for this family 40
million for this family and I'm like
where do those numbers come from you
know is it like what what's what's the
true cost of you know let's let's say
everything they accuse Alex Jones of
doing is like true and legit like how do
you get the 40 million dollars and for
that matter Kanye West goes on some
podcast and he goes I watched a
documentary by Candace Owens and it said
this is what really happened and now
he's got 250 million dollars you know
fine set the precedent because I got a
bunch of lawsuits I could file against
all the fake news and you know what if
they want to play this game each and
every one of you can sue all the fake
news outlets for every lie they put out
yeah let's do it I'm glad we're
revisiting the George Floyd stuff
because it really concerned me the
amount of drugs he had in his system
according to one Coroner's report there
are two coroners reports one the family
had done and they said he died I believe
it was asphyxiation that brought on a
heart attack the other one said it was
just a heart attack that killed him and
then you look at the drugs in his system
they said that he had levels of fentanyl
that were intoxicating meaning he was
high he was behind the wheel of a car
when they pulled him out he was
screaming if you see the second video of
him screaming at the cops that were
dragging him like trying to control him
to to take him out of the car put him on
the ground he's like put me on the
ground put me on the ground I'm gonna
die I'm gonna he kept screaming I'm
gonna die I can't breathe I can't
breathe he was screaming before they
ever put any knees or anything on the
guy like he was struggling he was in a
bad State I think he was freaking out
because he'd just been doing a speed
ball and he was behind the wheel of a
car felt like he was gonna go back to
prison or go to prison
um and he and he he the whole Terror
thing really pushed him into uh
I'm not saying the terror killed him but
you know Panic can cause people to die
you know your your heart can stop
um for things like that so yeah this is
important to talk about here's here's
the ridiculous thing PolitiFact says
Floyd did have Fentanyl and his system
at the time of his death as West said
however the Hennepin County Minnesota
medical examiner ruled the cause of
death was homicide due to
cardiopulmonary arrest
uh pulmonary arrests complicating law
enforcement subdue restraint and net
compression experts in toxicology
Cardiology and drug use stated death by
overdose was unlikely or impossible
so what we're dealing with is
Kanye West watched a documentary the
real lawsuit would need to be pointed at
the daily wire good luck with that
because here's how here's how the the
stupid system works I gotta admit it
it's a relatively stupid system
uh a news Outlet can publish a lie about
anyone here
and then let's say let's let's just
hypothetically say NBC News publishes
publishes a false statement effect ABC
then sees it and reposts it
NBC the original story delete it and
says whoops we were wrong but now it
still exists on the other outlet and if
you sue them they'll say we cited a
different website so you have to go
after them they'll say we already took
it down then 800 000 other news outlets
will will go to ABC and copy what they
wrote and there is nothing you can do to
get that stuff taken down absolutely
right yeah
what do you got your power outlet
from now on also donated two million
dollars to the George Floyd family a
couple years ago and it wasn't enough
they want more he's a compassion of
doing them for 250 million I mean I I
you know these cases are just frivolous
and it shows you how people are being
punished for expressing wrong think
that's not a society that is free that's
not a society that of course could allow
freedom of speech where's and again this
is something that that should be
important you could express any opinion
but because people get their emotions
hurt they could throw you in court and
waste your time and money that's just
crazy man Money Talks man so is this
because indefinite defamation cases uh
there has to be some way to prove that
there was uh like a loss of income or
something to that damages I mean mean
what are what are what are they claiming
like you know I don't know maybe this is
just uh a PR thing it's going to get him
a bunch of attention they're going to
get the it's a virtue signal it's going
to get them the the we're the good guys
fighting back against you know crazy
Kanye or whatever or they hope that he
has a a bunch of money he'll just settle
with them they'll get a few hundred
thousand dollars or something like that
uh you know maybe but but I also kind of
think he's the kind of guy who's going
to be like he's going to go to a lawyer
and just be like here's a million
dollars have fun yeah you know when
you're a billionaire like that you don't
really got to think twice about it if
Kanye had to pay restitution to these
this family would it be taxed the tax
restitution payments do you guys know I
don't know actually they might not
because it's like a donation he could be
like oh and here's an easy way to donate
another 50 million to this family if I
want to oh yeah that's a good point I
don't know I think I actually talked to
the lawyer about this and I'm not I'm
not I'm not exactly sure maybe people in
the in the chat might know better but
yeah that's an interesting point because
if you say you cost me a million dollars
you got to pay me the million dollars
back the argument is that you're already
negative the million dollars so it you
know what I mean like if I'm negative a
million bucks you give me a million
bucks I'm at zero you know yeah maybe
that's the argument I think this is
really an example of piggybacking off
the Alex Jones trial that we just saw
where where they they people that
weren't even named in yeah we've got a
buzz we're trying to figure out where
that's coming from it's not on my end
though it's not mine it's unplugged um
where people that weren't even named by
Alex Jones uh for the definition
there you go um people that weren't even
named were suing Alex for defamation
which is very odd because normally if
you're not named publicly then I don't
see what what basis you have or standing
you have and that billion dollar
settlement is like now people are
feasting they're like oh anything
anybody said about me that hurts my
feelings I can maybe get money for just
never describe people you know like just
just never identify someone in any
meaningful way
so like uh what did I say the other day
that everybody I said something about uh
annoying white liberal women on Twitter
you know who I'm talking about and then
everyone oh yeah I know and I was like I
I just said Annoying I don't know I
wasn't referencing anyone in particular
but everybody seemed to have someone in
mind so there you go that annoying white
liberal woman on Twitter you know I'm
talking about she is the worst she kicks
dogs it's like I didn't say I who did I
who Am I who am I accusing I'm like you
know non-descript if someone changes
their name to white liberal woman can
they retroactively Sue
all those people that went to Jeffrey
Epstein Island all of them they're all
bad they're all bad I don't know though
actually there's an interesting strategy
in defamation like
you know Luke if you were to call out
any one of those people who went to
Epstein Island and you say is a
statement of fact they did a thing they
might be able to sue you and you can say
oh no I'm being sued time to go to
Discovery show me all the communications
you've had with Epstein everything done
on the island and you could potentially
open it up to be like okay let's see
what you got and then you get them under
oath in front of a lawyer and you can
ask them the question directly so
strategic love fair I guess I you know I
think there's there's pros and there's
cons if you have the time and the money
though to deal with it you know because
you're right you get sucked into the
courts
and they just drag it on for years and
years and years you know you you're
paying an attorney you have to go to the
hearings it's just you know and I
someone someone like
West doesn't matter you know he's he has
an attorney does it do it but if they're
going after you know
people who don't have the funds and or
the means to be able to defend
themselves it becomes quite a problem Oh
you just lose instantly yeah people
really you really don't understand this
I mean if it you you can be just
outright shut down if you get sued and
you can't afford a defense like what do
you even do so now you have to have an
attorney to uh for free speech right to
be able to speak how you want to speak
you have to have an attorney there
backing up and a couple hundred thousand
dollars to defend yourself
yep
Money Talks for-profit lawfare I think
that's a problem yeah oh yeah I mean but
but lawyers provide the service I've
talked to a bunch of lawyers about a
whole bunch of other issues and there's
there's varying degrees of issues where
you know I've been defamed and they'll
say there's no there's no standing here
sorry you have no damages and then
they'll also say I mean you can sue them
and you know that it's just lawfare
basically yeah where it's like someone
defames you you know they defamed you
but they're protected by the precedent
times to be Sullivan meaning you know
you need actual malice or you can't
prove damages which is I I think that's
absolutely insane because then you end
up with a hundred news outlets all just
trying to destroy your ability to
fundraise but then how do you prove it
was their statements that stopped your
ability to fundraise so I'm thinking
about like project Veritas how often has
it been that project Veritas has has
lost a donation because of defamation
how do you know are you gonna go fine
You're Gonna Knock on a dorm back ma'am
do you ever heard of us okay would you
have done you would have donated to us
but oh you saw ABC well there we go now
I'll write that down that's damage no
there's no way to find those people so I
think there's pros and there's cons here
I I actually think
the solution to this should be
if you get sued
like if you sue someone for defamation
the immediate there there should be a
were you damaged by this and if so upon
proving fault the individual should
compensate you for the damages however
if the damages are ill-defined in either
context you should be forced to issue a
correction stating the facts so if Luke
said something like Ian once you know
threw a jar out the window and then Ian
proves it wasn't or Ian then Susan says
prove it and Luke can't then Luke would
have to be like I have no evidence to
support this claim or you know in the in
the instance it probably needs to be a
bit more specific than that but my point
is if someone says I did a thing I
didn't do and it's it's provably false I
should be able to sue them to force them
to publish a correction prominently to
to rectify the damaged reputation
because it's not just about money it's
about reputation in the long run and
then what happens if someone defames you
and the damages don't come until a year
later you know it's just there's got to
be a way to solve for this because the
media can just keep lying about
everybody and getting away with it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there